- [Narrator] K-pop band SHINee
is about to perform live
for more than a hundred thousand fans.
- [SHINee Members] (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] But none of
them are here in person.
So, fans have paid about $40 each
to watch the spectacle from home.
That's because during the pandemic,
K-pop is taking livestream
concerts to the next level
by blending real and
virtual worlds together.
Globally, many artists have
been livestreaming performances
for free on platforms like
Fortnite or Instagram.
- [SHINee Members] Hi, we are SHINee.
- [Narrator] But K-pop bands
are convincing fans to pay,
especially after global
revenue from concerts last year
dropped by 70% when
coronavirus restrictions
brought music tours to a halt.
- (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] We went behind the scenes
of SHINee's online concert
to see how these extravagant livestreams
can be a lucrative way to help
reboot the concert industry.
These online concerts
are called Beyond LIVE.
The concept was launched by the
K-pop label SM Entertainment
as the coronavirus swept
across the US and Europe
around April of last year.
- (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] Kim Sung-Hak's
company, Dream Maker,
creates stage designs using
immersive technologies
to enhance visual effects
in online concerts.
He says the idea is to deliver a show
that will be impossible to pull off
at a live, offline concert.
- (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] This is the
first Beyond LIVE performance
for SHINee, and it's taken
them some time getting used to.
- (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] In the past
year, Dream Maker has produced
11 livestream shows for other K-pop bands,
including Super M and Twice.
Kim says his team tries to recreate
the feeling of togetherness,
and for some bands,
FaceTime is a new part of
the concert experience.
- (speaking Korean)
- The last time I saw
them in person was 2017
when they came for the
SHINee World V tour.
So the most exciting thing
was just seeing them,
to be honest.
- [Narrator] Jenny Plyler is a SHINee fan
who lives in the US.
She says while she prefers
physically attending
a live concert, she's happy to
see her favorite band online
if that's the only possible way.
- Sometimes the concert just
doesn't come to your country
for whatever reason,
like their schedules don't line up.
(music beats)
- The unique thing that is differentiating
the K-pop movement in relation
to what others are doing.
It's a fan first approach,
which is really good.
I think it's a great approach for music.
- Mike Schabel is a concert
industry analyst in the US
and he says Western artists can learn
from K-pop's approach
to these online shows.
- It's the art in helping the audience
feel like their contribution matters.
You know, their cheering matters.
They feel like they're part of an event.
And that creates this
great dynamic and value.
- [SHINee Members] (speaking Korean)
- (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] Lee Sung-Su is the CEO
of K-pop label SM Entertainment.
He says his company had been working
on this new kind of fan
experience since 2012,
but the pandemic kicked it into high gear.
- (speaking Korean)
- [Narrator] And this advanced concert
comes with new revenue opportunities
by selling cheaper tickets
to a larger audience.
For example, SHINee's Beyond LIVE
is at least $20 cheaper
than its in-person concerts,
but the show could fill the
stadium eight times over.
Plus, Beyond LIVE sells
merch for the online events,
like a stand for your
smartphone to watch the show
or a fan light that syncs in
real time during the concert.
Lee declined to disclose total profits
from SM's Beyond LIVE concerts,
but said that the venture
has been economically viable.
Even the South Korean
government is taking a page
from K-pop's online concerts.
In March, it announced plans
to spend 17 million dollars
to create a virtual concert space
to help smaller entertainment agencies
and independent labels
reach audiences online.
But going virtual doesn't mean
the pandemic isn't a concern.
The band and staff have to
get their temperatures checks
and fill out a questionnaire
before the concert.
And when the pandemic passes,
the band says it's looking forward to:
- [SHINee Members] (speaking Korean)